[Music]
she's fiercely loyal as she said perhaps
problematically before the House
Committee yesterday she tells white lies
on behalf of the president so I assume
she will continue to defend him and do
whatever she can to protect him wherever
she may be
yeah it's left all of us saying define
white lie to find non-substantive lies
hope picks I had a very elevated
position with Trump and her loyalty to
him helped garner that but this is not a
battle-tested person who knows had
weather storms things are about to get
pretty ugly inside the White House and
the question is for somebody like hope
Hicks why did you say that long she's
got to get ready for Mahler she's got to
get ready for a trial
I mean it's things could get ugly Joe's
lost his mind obviously the destroyed
Trump media having their field day
following yesterday's announcement hope
picks that she was resigning a position
as White House communications director
joining us now with reaction he was
there himself former White House chief
of staff Reince Priebus all right first
of all I defy all of these phony
overpaid so-called journalists hypocrite
colleagues that that are lazy beyond
belief okay this is a white lie the
president would love to be on with you
liberal Joe but he's busy that day okay
meeting the president has no intention
or rights your tie looks actually it
looks great tonight when I really think
your tie looks hideous it's something
that's a white lie and they both look
you know I mean this is part of what's
driving money in the media is it's it's
Trump world it's trashing Trump it's all
part of what's been happening since day
one with with the president look I mean
you look at what it's like in the White
House you're working like a dog you're
getting destroyed in the press many of
these people are spending hundreds of
thousands of dollars on lawyers and you
know and you look at the results but you
have to go to hell and back in order to
get there John you know this is another
thing so the media will say okay well
Donald Trump is never going to be
somebody that he's not he's not going to
be the Pres
the mainstream establishment president
that they wanted elected they would have
had that with Hillary he's his own man
so if the president vents or tweets that
he's annoyed with something is that how
he makes decisions or is it part of a
process well that's just said I mean the
American people voted for a disrupter
but what I what I was try to explain to
people all the time is that the media is
obsessed with the decision making
process who's in who's out who's up
who's down a tweet of the day but this
is really how censoring makes decisions
he measures things out he measures
things out he puts really smart people
that might not agree with each other in
the same room but what I always tell
people focus on the results look at the
results remember four things federal
judges and Gorsuch Isis regulations tax
cuts those four things if you look at
the results of what this president has
accomplished and you you know ignore the
palace intrigue ignore what the media
wants to talk about every day that
really doesn't matter
you mean energy and a lot that hasn't
been accomplished I look at the
statistics today what a 49 year low yeah
and employment issues here's what I want
to ask you so atoms should look at the
Heritage Foundation he got look at the
Heritage Foundation the other day they
said 64 percent of his agenda and I
would tell you the Heritage Foundation
was they were no big Pro Trump
organization when Donald Trump went down
that escalator so it's not like there
are Trump cheerleaders out there making
these numbers up it's actually true let
me ask you this Adam Schiff is a mission
I thought Meghan McCain destroyed him on
the view I didn't watch we chose it and
I give I give her all the credit in the
world she did a phenomenal job Adam
Schiff oh it's all in the public arena
now about Trump Russia collusion I'm
like is there any evidence have you ever
seen anything because I haven't you know
I've never
seeing anything I've been told by
high-ranking members of the FBI as I've
mentioned before I won't get into it
again but they flat-out told me that one
of those articles the the original New
York Times article that apparently won
an award the other day for journalism
was overstated untrue and many other
things about it and these were people
from the FBI that told me this so look
you know I've never seen it I I know the
president hates it and in he hates
watching it but I always move forward
last question just because the president
vents at a meeting as he's making it a
decision I think I want to fire that
person what is the real process is that
does he do it when he says it or is a
part of a process
no listen there is a process there was a
process when I was there as the same
process that was followed by Ronald
Reagan and Bush 43 the there's a
principals committee where major
decisions are brought through with all
the principles of the White House major
departments General Counsel's they all
come up to the president with a decision
memo in hand presented to the president
for a decision now there are some things
though that the American people
understand that the president at times
gets tired of waiting on if he knows
what he's going to do about the issue in
regard to say transgender in the
military he's gonna make a decision he's
been talking about steel tariffs since
the 1980s I should not be a big fan of
steel tariffs but this is what president
Trump's agenda is all about and the
staff is charged with executing the
agenda of the president and the agenda
of the president is getting done and
it's working for the American economy
all right right it's always good to see
you thank you for joining us we
appreciate it